meteorologists are calling it a one-sena
generation weather event it's
complicating the once in a Year
festivities to say the least
a pre-Christmas Mass mobilization has
been stalled by high winds heavy
snowfall and flooding in freezing
temperatures a number of cities have
declared states of emergency including
New York I called it a kitchen sink
storm because it is throwing everything
at us but the kitchen sink
we've had ice
flooding
snow freezing temperatures
and everything that mother nature could
Wallop at us this weekend the Arctic
Blast has forced the cancellation of
several thousand flights and Counting
travel chaos is reflected on the roads
too in whiteout conditions around 50
Vehicles were involved in a number of
crashes here on Interstate 80 the Ohio
Turnpike
more than 200 million people are under
some form of weather advisory that's 60
percent of the U.S population
struck by the phenomenon dubbed a bomb
cycle
the storm intensifies really quickly you
can get uh very damaging winds and then
the winds over the water can create can
move water around so you get huge waves
uh storm surge uh coastal flooding can
be pretty terrible
the severe cold brings disruption but
also danger to life there have been
several deaths in Houston Texas a
homeless man in a wheelchair fell into a
fire pit he was found dead by
firefighters called to the scene
more than a million people have had
their power cut off as the storm battles
through North America before Christmas
it's seriously it dangerously cold I
mean
I would advise anyone if you don't have
to be out don't go out and if you do go
out well you need to
bundle up there is no right time for
conditions like these it's certainly not
right now
James Matthews Sky News in Washington